New York Times the first up she's a
Grammy winner and a two-time Emmy
winning comedian and actress who holds
the Guinness Record for most comedy
specials by a woman more importantly she
is a good American who loves her country
and should be able to work in it Kathy
Griffin
[Applause]
[Music]
love your new do I did I cut my hair
very very sure we're all shaving our
heads now the pissed off women we're
angry or shaving our heads just for fun
just scare you guys bill first of all I
really want to thank you for being one
of the first and only people to publicly
support me and say what happened was
[ __ ] celebrities that were like
don't tell anybody else that you're this
tech Gary Seinfeld Jerry Seinfeld okay
exactly I happen to know they don't well
we've missed you you know I mean if it's
true one thing nobody could ever take
away from it you are a hard worker I
love it man you love it you got where
you are through hard work you joke by
joke joke at a time baby I never had a
studio I never had a manager just out
grinding it out and that's what I love
doing so for you to have it all taken
away it just really pissed me off more
than anything because I mean look you
took a picture you took a very bad
selfie I blame the photographer I've
been on these photo shoots and they're
always trying to do something
provocative so they said hey why don't
you pull a key picture the wacky picture
and it turned out to be a little too
wacky
that's quite a key okay it was very
wacky and but you know if this wasn't
the United States of babies you know you
wouldn't the first thing you said was
look I went too far
I get it it should have been over okay
there she gets it fine but of course
everybody has to go batshit nuts about
everything all the time yeah and
actually the selfie analogy is really
good because almost like imagine if you
took the you had the worst selfie in the
world you went to bed and you woke up
and you found out that the president
tweeted about it which then mobilized
the alt-right
foxnews everybody else and then you know
they also thought it was illegal which
right tasteful but not illegal covered
by the First Amendment no I'm
I mean I went through something like
this yours is worse because you were
actually interrogated you were
determined federal investigation by two
departments from the DOJ the partner
justice right
I mean after 9/11 I I had this on my
wall for a while the variety headline
that says you know White House keeps
heat on ABC's yeah okay so and it was
bad Ari Fleischer was talking about me
in the press conference every day but
you had it far worse because you
literally had your livelihood taken away
from you yeah my show kept going we our
ratings never dropped
I even had my I was on in the middle of
a 50 city tour and I had like 25 dates
up until the following February because
this happened on May 30th TMZ was
reporting my show cancellations in real
time which scared
I think the theaters so these theaters
which I don't blame because all of a
sudden you know normally they do like
stomp or Mamma Mia and all of a sudden
they're getting robo calls from like a
thought farm in Macedonia going if I see
that [ __ ] on stage I'm gonna cut her in
the cup her head off and put her head up
her [ __ ] that was no joke that was the
number one reason that the folks who are
angry want to kill me that's the number
one procedure they want to do moving on
yeah it was it was ugly and and I mean
but it really got out of hand I think
when when the official security
apparatus of the United States of
America would you think would have
something better to do and I am sure
knew better that then you were somehow a
threat to the president well that
arrogated you you I mean flying is still
a problem for you yeah I mean you were
on the d-list now you're on the no-fly
list
the d-list is much better do way better
yeah I'm on the Interpol list and so
when I couldn't get work here after that
Interpol yeah international criminals
yeah so I did an overseas tour I did 15
countries in 23 cities and I was
detained at every single airport which
is frightening because they see they
scan your passport they see you know and
by the way this is really scary when
you're at the Singapore Airport and you
see the person go like this and then
there's like whispering and then they
put me in like a detention room and you
don't know how long it's gonna take and
I'm thinking you know I got it excuse me
I have an 8 o'clock show I got to make
soccer moms and gay guys laugh you know
let's go but but in all serious in all
seriousness there were times when they
took my devices they can do that and you
might think you know we all have our
rights but when you're in that moment
you're really at the mercy of one or two
people in that room
so it happened it happened LAX it
happened at London Heathrow and it's
scary every time because you don't quite
know what it is so if you had to do it
all over again
I mean assume you wouldn't take the
picture but I did my pants no I'm
kidding
[Applause]
once I waited to do that joke okay but
would you do anything over the way it
was the aftermath of it
oh yeah I mean everything about the
aftermath was you know it truly is a
historic situation so one of the things
I like doing about touring is as you
know you're on stage and you can really
tell your story without censorship and
stuff so the current show I'm doing
actually does have a look a couple
serious moments in it because when I
described the interrogation you could
hear a pin drop
you mean like I said I've just done 23
cities in 15 countries and the intensity
of those moments when my First Amendment
attorney said to me you know if this
doesn't go well you'll leave here in
handcuffs and the DOJ called my
attorneys every single day for two
months did you come in yet did she come
in yet they every day they called and
said we can do a it's called a no-knock
which is what they did to Paul manna for
sure no not come in you know and I'd be
like fine come on in we can take my
Backstreet Boys CDs you know so it was
crazy but that's how crazy it was so I
was determined to not do like a perp
walk so it cost me a lot of money of
course but at least we were able to
negotiate the interrogation happening in
my Attorney's Office but you know just
being told you could leave in cuffs yeah
you know I mean it came straight from
the DOJ in the White House so and that's
the that's the administration that we
have now so that's what I am here to
talk about is I really believe that it
happened to me and I really believe it
could happen to you and other people or
people's kids or relatives
it could happen it's gotten crazy well I
I mean we're not gonna hopefully take
that picture but I do believe what
you're saying in general is correct
everything that was unthinkable two
years ago is thinkable now dictatorship
fascism all those kind of things so we
award nothing is off the table right
okay so do you think so I know some
friendships were casualties in this I'm
down to three gay guys
and you but I hear your fluid I hear
your fluid which is very trendy very
trendy bill very hot sells tickets I'm
just gonna play straight man today I so
I got canned from CNN which sucked
because I was never seen an employee I
only worked there one night a week but
they made like this sweeping statement
and I was John jr. was like of all
people like Don jr. that freaking chrome
AG like right early human whatever his
deal is it was like Good Morning America
and says we don't just want to ruin
Kathy Griffin's career we want to
decimate her and that was like months
after the photo so but do you I'm not
decimated right no you're not
[Applause]
we need comedians I mean I know that
sounds like a pat on the back is on one
of them but what we really do especially
in this era and in any era to to
sometimes go over the line so we know
where the lines are and also to
establish that we do live in a country
with free speech that was as distasteful
it might have been to a lot of people it
was free speech free speech is still
kind of important enough you know so the
alt-right is kind of co-opted it like
right you know speech it Berkeley and
somebody knocks over garbage cans sets
it on fire and if it's an alt right
person to say that's free speech but
they kind of co-opted that but you know
you and I do the kind of comedy that
pushes boundaries and and to do that you
have to move them and then cross them
and push them again and see what works
and I'm finding like I know you're on
the road as well I'm finding that people
are wanting that kind of comedy or in
such an intense talking cat jokes no I
mean they definitely and they want to be
very mean to Donald Trump and I can do I
do have by the way of a small victorious
announcement okay okay so I'm dipping my
toes into touring again even though the
Trump's and nobody wants me to work
again but I'm dipping my toes in and I
just booked today I'm gonna do a show at
Carnegie Hall in New York
also I'm also gonna go right to Trump's
backyard and do a show at the Kennedy
Center
[Applause]